they're getting ready to celebrate Saint
Patrick's Day at this class for new
parents in their minds though it's the
budget it's delivered a pot of gold I
think it's really really helpful um we
would you know it would really make
things easier it would just make
Transition go back to work really easy
as well tax that we're having daily in
our household at the moment how we're
going to structure our finances all of
that kind of compound is this uses is uh
looking good isn't it hello what's your
name but it won't be looking good
immediately the three hours that
Chancellor's offering won't start until
next April and the full 30 hours for all
aged over nine months won't come until
September 2025. UK child care costs are
among the most expensive in the world
with full-time care for a child under
two costing on average 14
000 pounds a year but helping parents
out is one thing for child care
providers there are doubts over whether
Supply will be able to meet demand
this Nursery in Coventry they're
struggling to balance the books
like others they already provide free
child care to three and four-year-olds
but that comes at a cost current
government subsidies aren't enough it
means manager Claire Richmond may not
even offer the new hours it's less about
hanging on it's more about whether the
sector will support this at all I think
we're tired of being insulted with
funding rates as the years go on that
I'm not sure the sector have got the
energy for yet another battle to try and
save our businesses it seems fruitless
well
[Music]
the government says it will
substantially raise rates for providers
but after years of underfunding the
sector is skeptical
on top of that a rising bills and
falling staff numbers
sector that cares for others says it
needs to be cared for itself either
Bennett Sky News Coventry